this is the first edition of nature 1869
the Macmillan brothers had the idea to
create a journal that was dedicated to
the communication of scientific research
between scientists but also to the
general public
frontiers is the first and currently
only platform to combine open access
publishing with research networking we
like to think of frontiers as
community-based journals they're truly
driven by academic communities frontiers
started off back in 2007 and that
flourished quite quickly frontiers is a
small company with the very big vision
this has been clear from the very
beginning of our operations there is
hardly any major discovery and
fundamental science in the past that has
not been published in nature first the
innovation of four tiers involves
scientists from a bottom-up grassroots
way driving science forward taking
advantage of new technologies new ways
of communicating amongst each other
networking with each other
right
and it's great to have you here in
croydon surrey can't wait to show em the
coast wonderful very happy to be here
so Camilla it's great you're here and
great to be having this partnership with
less you talking now is so excited what
I think is really unique about this
partnership is that both frontiers and
at nature publishing group we're coming
from the perspective of the scientist
we're trying to figure out what is it
that we could do to help scientists and
help the scientific research process be
more effective and of course you're
right there on the front lines doing
research and your we were working
through this on a daily basis and we can
bring our expertise in publishing to
that mix I think we are not quite a good
position to tackle the problems that
scientists have and provide solutions
that really work in their working lives
i think the collaboration is great news
on the one hand you have nature as the
highest ranking scientific publishing
organ with many different branches and
on the other hand you have the most
progressive publishing group when it
comes to mechanisms of how to publish
your results and how to interact between
authors and reviewers it's a way for
scientists to maintain the control of
the work while also getting the
high-profile exposure that nature can
provide and frontiers can deliver
through its high technology and it's
only the beginning absolutely I think
what's special about frontiers is that
it's really designed for scientists to
have a publishing medium for them one
that they control nature is a top-level
Jonathan so to be involved related in
collaboration with them will be
fantastic for us this is going to give a
little opportunities for the scientists
to spread our studies it's the first
time that nature's entered into a
partnership with another organization
because we've never found another
organization that shares nature's vision
passion aspiration to help scientists be
more successful I think it's very brave
of nature but also very clever moving
from quite a traditional format to
income
frontiers is going to put them ahead of
the game I'm incredibly excited to be
working with frontiers there are very
innovative publisher who innovated in an
area peer review that I think has seen
too little development over the last few
years they're also like so many of us at
macmillan scientists so they've worked
at the bench they know what it is to be
a scientist I anticipation activities
that really speak to what we do at
digital science they've got a really
nice combination of innovation on the
editorial side innovation of the
technology side and that really speaks
to what we do have a million three
digital science with the software and of
course related publishing group if
people see that nature and frontiers go
hand and hand then it's clear that this
new way of doing science the way science
is published in frontiers is comparable
in importance so the way science is
published in nature I can see that
frontiers what I see aiming it
continuously improving the tools for
researchers and being very responsive I
think it's a win-win for everybody to
make that work you need to be able to
find each other effectively so you need
to take advantage of the technology
that's there but you also need the
credibility behind the scientific work
that you do and that's exactly what I
think frontiers and nature can bring
together
our strengths are really in innovating
quickly doing in new concepts to the
peer review to post publication
evaluation article level metrics to
providing open science tools and really
building great software this partnership
is great news for frontiers and I see
really this as a big driving force that
will help us reaching our mission of
creating an open science platform which
will be able to host every researcher
around the world from any academic
community as open science comes of age
we're going to be able to combine the
formal research papers and they're open
access with the tools of open science
and also the network that will allow
scientists to meet and collaborate with
each other online and together on the
frontiers platform we're going to have a
complete solution for scientists
throughout the world how we do it's
costanza 30 more publication the launch
of new joiners is going to have a huge
impact on the number of communities that
we will be able to reach out to we do
publish across the biological and
physical sciences and so we do have a
lot of depth but what you will bring to
the fore is a lot more penetration
within those communities and that's
going to be truly exciting we have to
attract new people into our fields in
particular young people as frontiers is
completely open access everybody out
there in the world can easily access the
articles together we really can I
believe change the way science is
communicated and serve scientists better
so by scientists for scientists and its
really the neck by side it's the next
generation of publishing his net exit
area is really looking forward to it
this partnership is going to be
incredibly important in the scientific
community not only will it give
scientists a new platform for publishing
the research but really importantly it
will give them a new platform for
connecting with
each other on topics that are important
to them and staying up to date with this
huge massive growing body of literature
you